so there's more DLC coming down the pipe
for battlefield 4 and I figure you're in
one of three camps number one you
already bought premium and you're gonna
play it so you can get your money's
worth
number two your somewhere on the fence
interested but not sure it's gonna be
worth 15 bucks and number three you're
not listening because you're playing
titanfall well I got some good news for
all you number ones out there the new
naval strike DLC is pretty darn solid
three of the four maps are very
enjoyable the new hovercraft is cool and
the new weapons are a nice little
garnish number two is you might find
something to tempt you here and number
three's well just have fun at your rodeo
let's start with the wave breaker map
the main feature here is the central
island which encloses a submarine base
with two channels running through it and
four big doors that can be opened and
closed to control entry to the compound
PwC's spawn in and outside the base for
speedy ingress and egress and attack
boats can maneuver their way in for some
explosive indoor action and if you've
got a real wild card player on your team
you might even see a little bird trying
to maneuver these narrow corridors in a
map pack not big on indoor spaces this
sub hangar is a standout for the way it
intertwines infantry and vehicle combat
obliteration matches are especially
excellent here as teams try to grab the
bomb from the deadly interior get out
past those fiendish doors and race to
the outlying islands to plant the bomb
naval strike also brings a new mode to
battlefield 4 called carrier assault on
omage - titan mode from battlefield 2142
it places two carriers on the outskirts
of the map and plays out kind of like a
conquest match that combos into a rush
match during the conquest Ematic aliy
bombard the enemy carrier on the lost
islands map that means zipping around in
a suite hovercraft with total disregard
for whether you're on land or sea this
amphibious vehicle doesn't handle like a
dream but it's maneuverable enough to
line up a target from far across a
strait or to wind your way over Hills
and deliver pillowy vehicular homicide
to your foes on this map you can also
move between islands on a quad bike if
you stick to the shallows and the
beaches around the central point are a
solid place to deploy the engineers new
anti-air mines these babies will score
mobility hits on helicopters making the
skies even more unfriendly than they
already were okay back to carrier
assault once you've beaten up the enemy
carrier by conquest aboard and attack
two successive rush crates there are two
ways to get in but only one big room for
you to enter and the rush crate is right
there
beware of enemies bursting through the
one-way doors though you might have some
leeway as they try to navigate the
poorly signposted corridors inside if
your carrier is breached you're in a
tough spot some of your team must return
to the ship to defend it while others
need to keep capturing points to breach
the enemy's carrier this last phase of
carrier salt isn't like rush in which
the defenders can hold out and
eventually win unless the defenders also
assault the enemy ship the capture point
bombardment will eventually destroy even
the staunchest crate defense it feels
like the kind of scenario in which a
commander would really help that or you
know being better at the conquest phase
operation mortar is the third map at all
Rocky Hill topped by an old fortress and
riddled with tunnels close quarters
combat gives you a good opportunity to
try out the new SW 40 a burly new
revolver that packs a nasty punch naval
strike also offers four new class
specific weapons recon gets the SR 3 3 8
a semi-auto sniper rifle that works like
a DMR but benefits from the sizable
scopes of the Recon class the engineer
gets a new PDW the SR 2 which probably
won't get a lot of use on the mid to
long range friendly maps of the DLC but
could be helpful
elsewhere support players have this
double drum fed LMG coming their way for
more Budda Budda Budda Budda Budda Budda
Budda Budda Budda and assault players
get both a new AR 160 and an underbarrel
grenade launcher that can fire three
little bombs before it needs to be
reloaded but arguably the coolest new
gun or at least the weirdest is the big
old tiny cannons on operation mortar no
they don't require a crew of powder
monkeys to fire and no it's not actually
that awesome it's slow and has very
limited range but when you get shot down
by one like you're in some lopsided war
between the medieval Ottomans and the
modern Aztecs in a civilization game
it's hard not to be delighted
the last map is Nansha strike and it
kind of feels like the test ranges Big
Brother there's not a whole lot going on
though the satellite Islands surrounding
it do add a bit of flavor to the
proceedings it just doesn't seem to have
the interesting elements or terrain
diversity that make the others so
appealing terrain diversity isn't a
naval strike strong suit as you might
expect but this oceanic expansion is
shaping up to be a solid addition to the
Premium Package and possibly a good pick
for aspiring shark hunters it'll be
available for premium members in late
March and wait did someone say shark oh
no
[Music]